[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Lan.
LAN TRAN: Hi, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: What
are we building today?
LAN TRAN: So I need to automate
some Admin tasks in Looker,
which is Google Cloud's business
intelligence and big data
analytics platform.
I've heard that it can be
done with Cloud Functions.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's right,
but I have to warn you,
I don't know Looker at all.
LAN TRAN: No worries.
If you bring your Cloud
Functions know-how,
I will bring my Looker skills.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAN TRAN: So I often need to
register Looker user accounts
for my coworkers, but
sometimes I forget
and people get annoyed.
So I would like to
automate that process.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, got it.
LAN TRAN: So my users usually
fill out a Google form
so that email addresses end
up in a Google spreadsheet.
Can we build a
Cloud Functions so
that it reads that spreadsheet
nicely and then creates Looker
user accounts for my coworkers?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, we can.
This is actually pretty common
use case for Cloud Functions.
Run on a schedule, read a Sheet
or some other data source,
and take actions
based on that data.
LAN TRAN: Sounds like Cloud
Functions is a glue [INAUDIBLE]
in the Cloud.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, that's
a good way of putting it.
Cloud Functions are great for
gluing together other systems.
LAN TRAN: So I look at
Cloud Function Documentation
and I saw that we can write
the functions in Python.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, we can.
Google Cloud Functions also
support node, go, Java, .NET,
Ruby, and PHP.
LAN TRAN: Good.
I know Python
pretty well, but how
do you read Google
Sheet in Python?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Here is an example.
First, it gets the
default credentials,
then it creates a service
object, then a Sheet API
client.
And we can call values.get
on that Sheet API client
and passing the Sheet ID
and range of cells to read.
But now it's my turn
to ask you a question.
How do you create Looker
accounts from Python?
LAN TRAN: It's pretty
simple, actually.
So we need to import the
Looker SDK like this.
We create an SDK object and
then we can call methods on it,
like the right user to
create new user account.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So I will go to my project
in Google Cloud Console.
And here I'll select
Cloud Functions.
I'll wait for it to be enabled.
And then I click here to
create a new function.
I give the new
function a good name.
And I'll make sure that
Require authentication has
been selected, so that it can't
be triggered by just anyone
out there on the internet.
And when I click Next here,
the Code Editor opens up.
Good.
So we can wrap these code
fragments in Python functions,
then we just need to tell
Google which of these functions
is the entry point.
That entry point should take
a flask or request object
as its only input parameter.
LAN TRAN: I think
between the two of us,
we know enough to
write this code.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's do it.
First, I'll write the imports.
And the first two
will be needed to read
the Google Sheet and the next
two import the Looker SDK.
LAN TRAN: And I will
write the function
that is the entry point.
It calls a function that
reads the email addresses
from a Google Sheet,
looks over these emails,
calls a function that creates
a Looker user account for each
of these email.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Then I will write
the function here
that reads email
addresses from the Sheet.
It will create a Sheet client
and call values.get on it,
and read all the values
from the B column.
I will open our
Google Sheet also
and copy the Sheet
ID from that address
and paste it into the Sheet
ID variable in our code.
LAN TRAN: Then I will write
the function that creates
user's account in Looker.
First, it calls create
user on a Looker client,
then it calls create
user credentials email
to set up new email for
the user's credentials.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
And I'll also put in our
requirements.txt file.
All right.
But Lan, how does
Looker know who we are
and what Looker project
we're adding users to?
LAN TRAN: So Looker will read
the base URL, the client ID,
and a secret from any file.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, got it.
OK, so we put it in there.
And I'll deploy the function
by clicking this button.
LAN TRAN: Let's
test the function.
MARTIN OMANDER: I'll
click here to call it.
Oh, that doesn't look good.
Let's check the log.
Something about permissions.
LAN TRAN: We never granted
access to the spreadsheet,
did we?
If I click Details, it
looks like the Functions is
running as [INAUDIBLE] account.
So I copied that, I go to the
spreadsheet, I click Share,
then I grant the viewer
access to the spreadsheet.
Click that test button again.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, here it goes.
Oh, looks like it works.
And the log, oh yeah,
the log says here
that the accounts were created.
LAN TRAN: But Martin,
there's one part
you have forgotten about.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Didn't we do it all?
LAN TRAN: No.
We have not scheduled
it to run nightly.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, you're right.
Let's do that in
Cloud Scheduler.
First, I'll copy the URL
that triggers this function.
Then I go to Cloud Scheduler
and click this button
to schedule a job.
I give a little name here.
I'll enter 00***, which
means every night at midnight
in the UNIX cron format.
Then I'll set it to your time
zone, Lan, Japan Standard Time.
I will set the
Target Type to HTTP,
and paste in the URL
for our Cloud Function.
And because the
function isn't public,
I will need to set Auth
Header to OIDC token.
I'll pick the default
compute account for now,
but if we take
this to production,
we should consider
creating a custom service
account that has
access to trigger Cloud
Functions and nothing more.
LAN TRAN: Yeah.
That's the principle
of the list privilege.
I like that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, exactly.
LAN TRAN: Let's
test it right now
so we don't have to wait until
tomorrow to see if it works.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, good idea.
Let's click this Run button
and give it a minute.
OK, I'll click View Logs.
Looks like it ran.
And if I remove all
these filters here,
we see the logs from
our Cloud Function too.
LAN TRAN: Great.
It's working.
Now I can just tell my users
to submit their email addresses
in my phone and Looker
accounts will be
created for them at midnight.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Thank you everyone for watching.
If you have questions for
Lan or me about this episode,
or feedback, or ideas
for future episodes,
please enter them in
the comments below.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]